i've talked about protagonists and
rivals so why not badass an overpowered
mentor characters we're talking about
those ever-present teachers who guide
our heroes provide a valuable ally in
times of need and often help unlock the
hero's true potential
and yeah i think some of you can tell
that this list was inspired by a fresh
new anime but hey before we get started
i'd like to direct your attention to the
hottest game in town dragon raja
dragon raja is an epic mobile rpg that
takes you to a grand world of adventure
with unbelievably high-end graphics
is the future of the mobile rpg genre my
favorite part of it
the sheer amount of customization
options customization is king in dragon
raja and largely due to its peerless
character creator you can practically be
anyone you want
in addition to the character creator and
the graphics it also provides you with
one of the biggest and most beautiful
worlds to explore
and that's not all for this april the
angels make their descent and invade
dragon range island
giving even season players a whole new
challenge yep you heard that right
it's a collaboration with the smash hit
anime evangelion for the duration of the
collab
you may take the fight to the angels
with limited collaboration some pilots
and items
such as a new limited vehicle in the
shape of eva-001
along with new outfits and accessories
the collaboration ends this may the 12th
so hurry up and join the fray and
download dragon raja now let me help you
get started on the party by providing
the download link in the description box
now without further ado
let's get started with the list
[Music]
handling egos and conflicting
personalities is hard the combustible
element of both gagashi's cold and
focused personality along with obito's
strong idealism would have driven any
mental crazy
good thing they've got none other than
the fourth hokage minato mentoring them
naruto's dad has been renowned as not
just a mentor to the trio of younglings
but also as the yellow flash of kanoha a
moniker that he deservingly got from his
feats of the fourth hokage his skills
have also led some to believe him to be
the child of prophecy who would someday
save the world he would then hold off
toby and give up his life in the attack
of nine tales
defeating it by doing the ultimate
sacrifice and opening the way for his
son to carve a legend of his own to
surpass him someday
[Music]
our next contender is black clover's
yami from appearance alone you could
tell that the captain of the black balls
is not someone that you want to mess
with beneath that gruff and tough facade
however
is a powerful mentor that will have your
back 100 of the time
yami's been one of the most integral
characters in the development of astha
and you have to say that a lot of that
has to come with the fighting experience
that this beast brings to the table just
look at how he handles his major fights
and trying to count the number of times
he's come to our heroes rescue he's got
a lot to show for his status as an
overpowered mentor
and if you want to see them for yourself
do yourself a favor and check the upper
right corner of the video to see some of
my older videos that feature this
amazing character
[Music]
always coming with a smile and a
reassuring look the powerful all might
makes his way to the list to the
surprise of no one we can't really miss
out the embodiment of justice and good
in the my hero academia universe now can
we besides his quote of heroic entrances
we can also count on all might to be one
of the bad ass mentors and teachers you
can have what i like about all might is
that we get to see various signs of him
through the story
instead of just being the invincible
hero that everyone's making him out to
be i personally resonated with his
understanding attitude and the way he
resolves issues with his disciples
mainly deku and to an extent bakugo i
know this is something that's not all
that rare
seeing various faces of the seemingly
fallible mental characters but almight's
case really felt special for me
especially looking at how the world
progressed after his main role finishes
badass and reliable all might is one of
my favorite anime mentors in recent
memory
it's time we go back to the old man look
with this badass who's next on the list
rayleigh
[Music]
the dark king a name that stirs fear to
people all across the seven seas
a prominent member of the roger pirates
in its heyday rayleigh now finds himself
chilling and enjoying life with women
however he's not since lost his edge
and he's the one who acted as a mentor
figure to teach luffy about the world of
haki with the passing of whitebeard
rayleigh takes over as a big cornerstone
of the heroic faction pulling several
awesome feats and great saves himself
throughout the course of the series he
may have been old but he still has it
and he still manages to throw it down
with the admirals i'd probably throw in
that old cliche saying of not judging
people by appearances
but that just doesn't apply to rayleigh
come on one look at him screams badass
he's got the edgy call factor down if
we're talking about appearances here
luffy couldn't have asked for a better
person to teach him haki count on the
overpowered guy without a devil fruit to
do the job for him
[Music]
to resume the list we go to one of the
more underrated series in my opinion
history's mightiest disciple
[Music]
how about continuing with a bang with
none other than the strongest person
alive
at least according to residents of the
genici universe that's right
we're going with hayato farinji
undefeated elder of the rio zampaku dojo
with his imposing stature and advanced
age
he embodies one face of the
stereotypical mentor character in
appearance however i don't think he's
anything but that
behind the gentle outlook is a look of a
master you can trust the most
he's strong but i think he's as cool as
badass mentors come
mainly due to his gentleness and the
appearance that he's someone that you
can trust with all your heart
don't let the warm welcoming dad feels
let you forget his power though it's
probably not much in the wide world of
anime but this
is a guy who can run on water move too
fast to be seen on camera
throw bombs to humongous heights and all
of that without even trying
if you were to ask a random guy who they
think the strongest member of universe 7
is they probably wouldn't immediately
pinpoint the extremely campy and
effeminate guy lipstick
still whis is probably one of the better
mentors goku can have
being the one to personally train him
and vegeta to unlock their god forms he
also helps them out with the frieza saga
and he can manipulate timelines to help
our heroes
whis is also the embodiment of divine
intervention in the dbz universe
according to some fans
and i'm inclined to agree with that
looks can be deceiving indeed don't let
the flamboyant looks fool you guys
fourth is everyone's favorite tentacle
alien goro sensei
is quite the wild card here introduced
first as a supposed villain who
destroyed the world he gives our
students the one girl to assassinate him
and save the world now we all know
that's a ruse right
because behind that threat lies a very
compassionate teacher who has the
ability to bring out the best from his
students i'd say for the job he took
goro sensei is quite overqualified
is there anything that he can't do it
doesn't seem like it right even in terms
of combat
no amount of military prowess can seem
to best him looks like our students have
their work cut out for them however
given a teacher that can connect to his
students as much as goro sensei the
eventual time of partying has got to
hurt those affable threats of destroying
the world aside will eventually find out
that goro sensei himself is quite the
touching and troubled past he could also
explain the empathy that he shows making
him one of the best teachers you could
ever have
[Music]
hey
not all anime mentors are kind and
accommodating though how about an anime
mentor that's the embodiment of the
phrase
tough love taken to the logical extremes
that's how we arrive with rurouni
gentian's hiko seijuro
ruthless and cynical hiko sejuro is not
the everyday image of an anime mentor
that people can typically think of he's
more of the
teacher from hell type that starkly
contrasts the warm and accommodating
aura that people like hayato give
instead he's cold and seemingly
unemotional despite caring for kenshin
beneath that aura
in a way that kind of attitude also
befits him being the most powerful
character in the series
heck if he got involved in the kyoto arc
we could have seen an end to shishio's
conquest much earlier but that would
have made for good storytelling now
would it up next is gojo
coming in in second place
if you guessed i got the idea to make
this list from jujutsu kaizen
come up and claim your cookie i'm pretty
confident with saying that gojo sensei
probably stole the show in jujutsu
kaizen practically all of his moments
are mind-blowingly cool and i dare say
he's part of the reason jiu-jitsu kaizen
became such a hit his moments are all
visual spectacles and we see the
internet blowing up
every time he comes in and does
something really cool i don't want to
spoil the manga any further but when the
bad guys are actively revolving their
game plan around you
and how they can keep you from
intervening it's got something to say
about the strength that you have and the
threat that you present
i've long had a rather soft spot for
anime mentors but i think the gojo
sealed the deal for me he's arguably one
of the coolest and most badass anime
mentors out there but he's not
first place on this list why is that so
well there's someone
way way way more overpowered than he is
in terms of respective universes
because of course when it comes to being
an overpowered mentor
few come close to mr one punch man
himself saitama the hero above all
heroes no villain stands up against the
might of saitama and that's earned him
the adoration of the people who knew his
prowess in the one punch man world
for the few of you who haven't watched
one punch man let me briefly tell you
what saitama's all about this unassuming
baldi was inspired to be a hero and
trained himself to hell and back the end
result
a hero who can defeat any foe with one
punch
and yes i mean that that doesn't mean
saitama's just a caricature of course
someone as strong as he is could
inevitably fall into the trap of
becoming boring but saitama actually
comes up with a pretty unique outlook on
life instead of being the go-getter hero
and defender of justice people can
picture him as he's actually quite the
cynical anti-hero
with some good points about the whole
hero industry the greatest hero and one
of the most interesting characters in
modern anime saitama tops off the list
of my favorite overpowered mentors so
who's your favorite overpowered mentor
character in anime tell me why or why
not in the comments section below i hope
that you enjoyed this list and if you
want to
you can also give suggestions on what
other lists you want to see on videotube
next time if you enjoyed the list and
want to see more content like this
please hit that subscribe button and
ring the bell you can also try
supporting me on patreon by being a
channel member
so that i can come back with a bigger
better vineytube moving forward
don't forget to check out the sponsors
of this video dragon raja
the link's in the description i'll end
with that for now and i hope to see you
again next time
[Music]
[Applause]
you